[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and if the Blue Beetle
trailer is bugging you out then this is
the video for you packed with Easter
eggs hidden details and things you
missed there's a lot to talk about in
this brand new First Look throughout
this video we're going to be breaking it
all down we're going over who the
character is in the comics and their
long and Rich history that's got us to
this point this was originally supposed
to be an HBO Max release but it's now
been pushed to a full theatrical one and
James can is hinder that he's bringing
this character into the DCU last year I
was thinking they were gonna back early
entire thing but Warner Brothers must
have a lot of faith in the film to
upgrade it to a full release now the
trailer follows Jaime Reyes says he's
given the Blue Beetle Scarab and this
transforms him into the titular
character the trailer does a brilliant
job of introducing us to his family and
it also pretty much shows all of the
scarabs powers and what it can do now as
for Jaime he's one of the many
iterations of Blue Beetle that we've had
over the years the first version was
originally created by Charles Nicholas
watchkowski all the way back in 1939
several companies have on the rights to
the character with him originally
belonging to Fox Comics before this
changed to Charlton DC then bought the
rights of the characters back in 1983
and this came in a package deal along
with characters like Peacemaker and the
question Allenmore originally wanted to
use these for Watchmen but DC kicked off
and thus he had to do ones that Rift on
them for the final release obviously DC
were kicking themselves so yes after
that they didn't let him use the one
side board because they had a last
writer with the Watchmen and ended up
having to do what they did with Doomsday
Clock anyway the original Blue Beetle
was called Dan Garrett who was the son
of a murdered police officer given
special abilities by a sacred Scarab he
became the hero of a weekly radio serial
and his own comic book line we actually
see his costume later on at the end of
the trailer in the center of the models
this is next to the one that followed it
with a red bell Boot and gloves now
there seems to be a mannequin with a
missing costume as well and this could
be hitting at someone else being out
there wearing the costume that maybe our
second version of the character now that
man was called Ted cord and during the
crisis on infinite storyline he was
taking over into the DC Universe along
with the other children characters Ted
was more of a scientist and it was sort
of the Blue Beetle Scarab had been
destroyed I think at the end of the
trailer we can see the characters coming
across his lair which is why they all
have the scientific tech there they say
it's like Batman who of course uses
Gadget and we can see Jaime looking over
a power belt his sister Milagros checks
out energy shield and George Lopez
Stoops around in some cupboards and
calls Batman a fascist internet ain't
gonna like that mate spoiler alert
they're gonna be kicking off
anyway though you might assume Lopez is
going to be playing his dad this is
actually his uncle Rudy his love
interest Jenny is also at the back of
the room and this is likely showing them
about the basement in court Industries
we can see the name caught on the tower
at the beginning and my guess is that
we're gonna be learning about how Ted
found the Scarab and then they come and
he took it experimented on it and then
Jenny snuck it out like what we see
she's very much a Gwen Stacy and Amazing
Spider-Man archetype and will probably
be sort of like layers from Spider-Man
Homecoming in that it doesn't really go
anywhere now I'm saying that is because
in the comics Jaime ends up getting a
character called 13 from Young Justice
real name Tracy Thurston I'm guessing
Jenny will be the girl he's after first
done the movie before he gets his
Thurston for Thurston
now it's possible that Jenny is based on
Jenny Quantum who was his friend in the
comics too oop friends on anyway she was
a member of Young Justice as well but
she ended up leaving the group to then
go and explore the Multiverse now back
to the comedy and we know that in the
film Susan Sarandon will be playing
Victoria cord who in the comics is Ted
Court's sister CEO code industry she was
first introduced in Blue Beetle
graduation day issue too and she became
one of the first foes the character
clashed against in that run Sharon Stone
was initially in talks to player but I'm
guessing they watched Catwoman and went
with Susan instead anyway cordovan she
became a member of the JLA but he was
killed during the Infinite Crisis event
again going back to the mannequin I
think he might be out and about in the
world and potentially had to run away
due to his sister's experiments oh at
one point in the trailer we also see
them flying out in the bug I'm guessing
this is called with them using it
to escape the skyscraper and head home
the bug pulls from the comics and if it
looks familiar then this is because this
is what was adapted into night owl's
Archie and Watchmen now the third Blue
Beetle after Ted court and Dan Garrett
is the one we're gonna center around in
the movie and as I'm sure you can guess
that is Jaime Reyes he'll be played by 9
and though they're kind of ripping on
the comics there are some things that
are altered from it in that he
discovered the magical Scarab which
attached itself to his back and this
gave him the armored battle suit with
enhanced abilities now though it was
though that it had been destroyed whilst
Ted was in the role it turned out that
he'd actually found it in a pyramid This
was later lost on the rock of Eternity
and when this was destroyed it ended up
hurtling it across the world which is
where it landed in El Paso Jaime
discovered it at this point and the rest
is history now they are changing things
up slightly from that and instead of
having it in El Paso we're heading up
the fictional Palmera City this new
location in the DC Universe was first
introduced in Blue Beetle graduation day
and he keeps it with the motif of the
comic Publishers inventing new places
for their Heroes to inhabit at least I
hope Palmyra said he's fictional cause
hell if it's not I'm gonna be in
deep deep
anyway pronouns I've already pronounced
everyone's name wrong so don't kick off
uh we start off with homie and his
sister working at a resort and from
there we go to their home life out away
from the city in the more impoverished
areas this juxtaposes the opening of the
teaser in which he's posing like one of
the elite that owns a mansion always
hits the thumbs up button and has a
wealth of YouTube subscriptions To
Mediocre channels like the one you're
watching right now so hit that subscribe
button if you want to achieve your
dreams see you chump now we next see him
go into what's later said to be a job
interview at court Industries I'm
guessing it's a similar thing to Oz core
where they have internships is Jenny is
there as well similar how Gwen was in
that movie not 100 of my American school
uniforms because I'm not a weirdo mate
uh but I'm pretty sure this is a school
jacket with a patch on it denoting his
in the comics you enter El Paso high
school but with a change up to Palmyra
City they may have altered that as well
anyway we see him sitting in the lobby
with other possible applicants beside
him before gweny judge Jenny comes down
and gives him a big belly burger box
this fictional fast food chain has
appeared in the DC Universe at several
points and It's featured in CW's flash
quite a fair bit the mascot is a big
bearded guy just like in the comics and
this is made to look like John Byrne who
invented it for DC after opening it up
we see some fries and also the Scarab
where the burger should be after picking
it up this immediately jumps out at
Jaime it does a sort of face agaronim
and it electrocutes his uncle and then a
Transformer it's very much foreshadowing
that this has a little side to it and it
carries this idea of body horror as we
watch you take over him now the Scarab
is very much its own life form and it's
a sort of parasite that brings with
Incredible abilities I don't know if
parasite is the right word but Jaime is
unable to remove it from his back and it
can also communicate with him
telepathically in the comics the first
night it attached itself to him seen it
inducing powerful hypnotic dreams and I
could see them even doing some stuff
like what we get with Venom by that I
mean the Scarab kinda goes back and
forth with Jaime and this adds a lot of
the action scenes and also the dialogue
it talk about how it can control its
host and he may have to wrestle with it
and turn it away from being the world
destroying machine that Jenny says it is
Jarvis and Tony of course also had some
nice banter back and forth in the MCU
and having this internal dialogue just
allows the character to kind of sign off
their thoughts in a natural way Comics
are of course able to show characters
thoughts whereas it's a lot harder in a
film so having something like this would
work really well to let the characters
spout off quips personally I think it
sounds more like Karen from homecoming
and again they are leaning into this
sort of Spider-Man idea because if it
ain't broke don't fix it the show of
Susan Sarandon has his saying that it
chose him and obviously this whole
thing's gonna be about how he has a good
heart and that's why I went to him
instead of her he has his family's
values too and like his Uncle says with
gray power comes great catchphrase you
know he's gonna care he's our next
Spider-Man yeah for sure easily right
right oh yeah he mixed up easy for sure
okay he's our next Spider-Man okay he's
gonna kill the franchise we know exactly
what's going on everybody knows Blue
Beetle yes when you think Blue Beetle
you think Spider-Man they're right next
to each other okay okay I was kind of
like I was like I still remember who's
bigger like boobie or Spider-Man every
time I watch Spider-Man I'm like oh Blue
Beetle coming up next yeah Blue Beetle
really did that first though yeah for
sure for sure I believe takes his first
flight and we see him overlooking the
entire world it shows the power he's
been given but it also cements that it
can control him and not the other way
around now from here we go to Jenny
opening a deal to what I'm guessing is
the basement in court Industries there
are rumors that Jason and sudokus will
be playing Ted in the film but they've
been denied like an Andrew Garfield
Photoshop even though we've seen it in
4k mate we've all seen it the next
weekend of us being cut in half with
Jaime's perception of time changing as
it goes on this is sliced by an energy
shield and it's something that the
character had in the comics now if
you've played the Injustice games then
chances are that you've either photos
Blue Beetle or if Smith smashed him like
it's a dislike button on a ryanairy
video shut the up ryanairy anyway
the Blue Beetle has a number of
different powers and these include
flight superhuman strength and
metamorphosis His Hands and Body in the
suit can shapeshift and change into
different Weaponry meaning that you can
pull off some sweet combos in Injustice
2 shout out by the game now this
Weaponry tends to be based around sound
energy and pyrokinesis making it
non-lethal he also has mechanokinesis
which means it can alter and manipulate
machines pretty cool skill set and
depending on what the situation calls
for the scab can take off and help out
we then get high me at home with his
family and this kind of gives us a Miz
Marvel setup where she's learning to
deal with her Newfound abilities whilst
also living at home where they
differentiate though is that Jaime's
family know about it instantly here and
this is more them helping him deal with
his power rather than him hiding it we
then see a machine powering up and quick
disclaimer the trailer we got isn't
super high quality so it's difficult to
make take out little details like this
like like what they are but they do seem
to be miniature scarabs we have the
electricity as well which is similar to
what shot out at Rudy and the
Transformer at the beginning of the
trailer Victoria cord clearly finds out
about him early on and we see SWAT team
members start to swarm his home his
family held up and later on we see Jaime
beating the same SWAT team members up
underground possibly leading off the
back of this scene now in between this
we get a shot of carapax the
indestructible man a major antagonist of
the Blue Beetle he was an archaeologist
that they could end up using to explain
how they've managed to get their hands
on the Scarab in the girl makes he came
across an indestructible robot suit and
they might end up using this later on in
the film and this was red and
potentially the power cells we saw
charging up before could be the suits
starting up failing to get control of
the Scarab might have pushed Victoria to
create her own which could lead to him
having this sort of reverse Scarab suit
now he does this sort of usual villain
stuff talking about how all the love he
has for his family is in fact a weakness
it's not exactly A1 writing don't expect
this to be an Oscar winner but he's sort
of going to be a first villain that
forces the hero to get to grips with his
powers we then see the bug flying out
and this seems to go to an island
potentially where the Scarab was
discovered it's a giant rock potentially
referencing the rock of Eternity and
this could be where they find Ted court
at he also see the family home then
getting destroyed and this is following
the motif that Jaime's new abilities
have brought across with them he then
creates a giant sword using the suit and
this looks very similar to clouds from
Final Fantasy VII the Buster shows this
Busters a big Buster but he loves video
games so we bloody love him anyway the
trailer ends with them in Court's lab
and his sister is wearing an overall
with Royers on it looking like a
mechanic we can also catch in Area
51 arcade cabinet which no prices for
guessing is about aliens as his uncle
Rudy slags off Batman we can all also
catches sarcophagus in front of him
sighing back to the whole archaeological
idea anyway that ends the trailer and
I'm guessing that some of you might want
to pick up some Comics involving the
character so the best place to start is
probably Infinite Crisis as that kind of
recount a lot of the main events with
and the backstory of him after that you
want to get Blue Beetle volume seven yes
that's a volume seven as it basically
Bells off the back of Infinite Crisis I
think they might have updated it to be
called Blue Beetle Jaime Reyes volume
one but I've got no idea mate got no
idea now now I'm guessing this
primarily will just be an origin story
and we'll probably just follow things
laid out in his secret Origins I'm
actually happy we're getting an origin
story for once you know I've missed them
a bit and we kind of had this trend
where characters like ironheart and so
on were just thrown into movies as
characters without us really learning
who they were first I just want an
origin story so I can get attached to
them and yeah this movie at least seems
to be doing that alright so my thoughts
on the trailer you know I kind of have a
weird relationship with DC and I've
often said that no one hates DC more
than DC fans I do think Shazam Fury of
the Gods show that they've kindly killed
the buzz around these movies by
basically announcing that they don't
matter spoiler alert though we are in
insignificant Speck of dust in the
cosmos that's barely a lie for a blink
of an eye on what comes the vastness of
time and space and in the end nothing
matters at all not you not anyone you
know and certainly not some DC movie
could be fun though right and back to
the initial point I think that they have
kinda killed the hype for this a bit
personally I think that James Gunn's a
great director and writer but but he's
just a crap Hollywood exec guys probably
cause the studio a lot of money
announcing that things don't matter and
he also spends a lot of time on Twitter
arguing with people which you never see
my uncle Kevin foggy doing so yeah I've
just had no hype for the upcoming DC
films and have kind of thought that
they're just releasing them for the sake
of it so we can get the reboot in a
couple of years the drama around EC has
overshadowed their products and it's all
been a big mess saying that though this
looks good and I am excited I think
Jaime is one of those Underdog
characters that can really grow into
their own and she'll of course killed it
in Cobra Kai guy is a great martial
artist and I think they can do a lot of
cool things with him though DC seem to
be determined to just ruin their entire
universe personally I think this
actually looks really good and it is a
shame that the drama kind of overshadows
everything the Blue Beetle is kind of a
series character that the studio can
build up and then I don't think it's
going to be a massive movie I do think
they can build up towards something
bigger down the line when he grows in
the role I'm guessing that they've also
not spent that much in the movie with it
originally being an HBO Max release and
it's probably gonna be a win-win for the
studio also nice to see a Latino
character getting some love they've
always been reduced to either being
Sidekicks or minor characters but yeah
you know what I hope it does well and
this first look it really got me on
board so yeah quite excited for it now
even with all the ongoing DC drama now
I'd love to hear your thoughts on the
trailer we've got lots of trailers out
at the moment so make sure you comment
below and let me know we are in a
competition right now giving away the
Superman 4 game box set to 3 subscribers
on the 15th of April and all you have to
do to be when the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the teaser
we beat the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners are the
last one are on screen right now so
that's you then message me on Twitter at
heavy spoilers you want something else
to watch you want to see our original
thoughts of the trailer and definitely
check out our reaction over on our heavy
spoilers Clips Channel that'll be linked
on screen right now a bit of a side
Channel where we do smaller videos more
more things just not doing breakdowns
and yeah definitely head over there
subscribe as well please and hopefully
I'll see you on the next one you take
care peace